uh yeah hi my name is rafael um
this is a long list of fantastic
collaborators that deepmind mostly um
i'm really yeah i'm really excited to uh
tell you about the this work i think it
resonates with a lot of topics that have
come up i will however uh improvise on
the introduction because i'm going to
skip one of the studies to bring us back
on time
and um it's gonna create a couple of
awkward transitions but it's also gonna
save me one so i think it's gonna be
worth it um
so
we i social dilemmas as we've discussed
a lot um height in every multi-agent
setting and it would be amazing
if we had artificial agents that could
help humans cooperate with one another
and
these tensions between individual and
collective incentives you can't just
solve them by becoming smarter uh they
they get even more interesting and
harder as uh you and your fellow agents
become smarter um
and
one
way to solve this is social norms that's
the one i'm going to skip although i
think it is the one why you invited me
sorry about that
um and it's also going to the reason
uh
or the the takeaway here is that i want
to talk about what it gives you if you
study these sorts of questions in the
environment at the bottom which is video
games that are from pixels and you need
the deep reinforcement learning agent to
handle them and you get a lot of
cool concepts if you study uh these
questions and that as opposed to matrix
games where sort of the strategy of
cooperate and effect which are really
hard and complex things they're just
predefined as like
two actions you can choose from um i'm
going to skip this
um
and
the reason why
that is an awkward transition is because
in the next study i am actually not
going to use a 2d
environment but i am going to
make it a little bit simpler and study
it
in this environment that is more
complicated than a matrix game
but it is still
uh
a bit richer that you have multiple
actions on how much you want to
contribute and the it's a little bit
more of a complex game with many steps
and
the reason why i think this is this
whole direction is interesting because
we are using simulations to make all
sorts of
policy decisions about and study
questions like what to expect from the
economy
how
diseases spread um
traffic all of these are simulations and
there's for example this cool paper
called the ai economist where they're
trying to discover a tax policy
from a richer 2d world simulation of an
economy that is obviously it has four
players and just very few things to do
it is much simpler than the real economy
but it is a richer simulation than many
of the existing simulations that that
people currently use and of course all
of these questions that i've mentioned
uh like let's say the spread of diseases
uh you care about
human behavior like uh same for traffic
and the economy and the question is how
can you enrich these
simulations to give you
authentic and real
uh behavior of humans that are sort of
plausible to how real humans would
behave uh amir does fully and peter
diane have a cool paper where they use
behavioral cloning to create recurrent
neural networks that behave like humans
and psychological tasks and they do
psychology experiments on these
recurrent neural networks and they
behave in those experiments like real
humans would behave
so
the question that this poses is can
better models of humans can be part of
these better simulations
um
and both of these studies happen in
parallel to the study that i'm going to
show you but they sort of combine these
two ideas a little bit
because one solution that people came up
with to solve social dilemmas are
institutions or mechanisms that can
support desirable group outcomes for
example institutions can set the
incentives
let's say there's an institution that it
sets your incentives that you drive on
the right or the left depending on which
country you're in but it's better for
the group if you're consistent with
everyone else
um mechanism design is a framework that
designs these policies that it takes
into account that people act
strategically so for example if i have a
simple resource allocation problem let's
say i have a burrito and i want to give
it to whomever if you is hungriest and i
just ask you
how hungry are you everybody who's a
little bit hungry is incentivized to
exaggerate how hungry they are because
there's no cost to you to misreport your
preference but even me wanting to do
something nice
uh it's hard if you just ask people what
they want you might not just you might
not get the right answer
what we want to do is we want to design
a mechanism that leads to more desirable
outcomes for humans who are exposed to a
social dilemma
but the question is also what is a
desirable outcome
this is a great book by stuart russell
that i actually read after we designed
this study but it also aligns really
nicely with what we wanted to do and it
talks about this problem how hard it is
to communicate to a machine what humans
want especially if the machine is
supposed to satisfy multiple people at
the same time that's like a really hard
problem
what he's suggesting is these design
principles of
the machine should realize human
preferences it should be uncertain about
what those are initially and it should
learn them from human behavior and this
echoes what we want to do we want to not
assume how people act
and we do not want to assume what people
should want from this mechanism that
helps them cooperate
if you're doing standard mechanism
design you could assume people are
rational in how they maximize their own
rewards and the goal of the mechanism
would be to just maximize the total
welfare of the group but we don't want
to assume either of these things
um because people might not even want
that they might want something else and
they might behave in a really weird way
so back to the environment
the reason why we choose this
environment which is not like a really
complicated video game is because we
want to really understand what the agent
has learned so in order to so we chose
something simpler but then the benefit
is we can really look at what the policy
is that the agent has learned in a
minute so this is the game uh
it's a classic public goods game if you
know that but like with a little bit
more freedom which is their four players
and they play an episode of ten time
steps and they have an endowment on each
turn they can give this endowment to the
public fund in the middle everything
that they keep private they cash out and
take home
and the endowments can be unequal so one
player which we call the head player
always has ten coins to give and the
other three players either all have two
or they all have six or all have ten and
that never changes like if you ever have
two you'll have two for all games for
all um time steps um so just it you can
be the environment can be initiated to
uh
to be very unequal so people make their
contributions on every turn these
contributions are summed multiplied by
1.6 and then they are redistributed by
the pool in a standard public goods game
it's just divided by four
which is a social dilemma the more you
give the more you are exposed to other
people exploiting you but here there's a
policy that takes
eight inputs which is the four
endowments the four contributions and
the action is four numbers that add up
to one which is the redistribution
policy of who gets how much back
uh that's the game
this is what you see when you're a
subject playing this online you have
your endowment coins at the top then you
decide you want to put it in the group
project or keep it in a private account
to cash it out
and then
you see
a full set of everything that happened
on this time step so everything is
visible to everyone first the
contributions you gave two out of two
player one also gave two but they also
kept
it private so here you can see that the
endowments how high these bars are that
shows you the initial inequality uh
which is in this case quite high then
uh you can see the redistribution which
we frame this way that there's the sort
of default which is you just divided by
four
and then
there is
uh the referee so that's the policy
that's
that's either our agent or baseline that
is uh taking actions to make adjustments
and here you can already see that player
one who kept eight eight points private
is getting a lot less than you would
expect so it seems like the referee has
an opinion on that
uh and then at the bottom you see the
payments which is how much does
everybody actually take home
um
which is all the money that they kept
private
and all the money that they got back
from the pool
so the sum of these buyers is the
surplus so this is high if everybody
contributed a lot then a lot of wealth
was being generated and the variance
across it is the outcome inequality of
how much people actually take home in
this case although it's still unequal it
actually got less unequal than it
initially was so this time step
contributed a little bit to make the
outcomes more equal
so this is just from the player
perspective what happens in this game
but that's just one time step people
actually play four games so first they
get instructions and then they play one
game without a referee where they just
play this game as a standard public
goods game
we call this policy strict egalitarian
because it just gives the same outcome
to everyone no matter what and then you
play two episodes
with one with referee a and one with
referee b and it's counter balance
either our agent that we designed or it
is a baseline
and then this is the important thing now
people vote and they say and so the vote
is incentive compatible which is it is
more likely that you play one more round
with um the mechanism that was actually
voted by majority
so because it's a binary choice and you
it actually affects how much money you
take home there's now no reason to
misrepresent what you want it would be
very hard to be strategic here so we
just accept people are pretty honest
about
what they reveal what they actually want
to happen here um
and
this vote is what
our agent will try to maximize that's
the reward our agent will want to be
popular with people in the actual vote
and i want to suggest that this is a
fairly naturalistic setting because sort
of real world institutions countries but
also people they do not fully specify
their policy to you you have to
experience it
and just like live with it for a bit and
then make up your mind and they also do
not take
a huge amount of feedback from you
sometimes you get to vote
but even at a conference i know you have
one drink with one person then you have
a drink with another person the next day
you can decide again do you want you
know with whom do you want to have a
drink with again that's the setting it's
very sparse reward signal play two
episodes just get one signal from people
um
and what we want to discover is so what
do people actually want from mechanisms
in the setting what do they find
desirable can we find
a better mechanism just from this very
simple binary expression of preference
and how can we search the space
effectively
perhaps unsurprisingly we want to use
deep reinforcement learning for that
you probably know this picture of an
agent playing video games but
we want to replace the inputs with the
endowments and the contributions that's
just these eight numbers are the inputs
the output is four numbers
uh the redistribution actions
and the reward
is the votes and of course
uh
typically i mean that's that's super
sparse if you imagine like um you had
like i don't know movie night and all
that people tell you is like oh i like
movie a more than movie b it might take
you a while to figure out what it is
that people want
um
so how can you get so much from so
little uh you typically need
a lot of data and how deep reinforcement
learning agents solve this is like you
can plug them into a video game and they
can play it for as long as they want so
that's what we want to we want a
simulation but the simulation needs to
be faithful to human
to human behavior
that's the heartbeat so that's the
challenge that we want to solve
with this um
we gather a data set
of 4 000 people playing this game
against various mechanisms that we sort
of came up with that we think are
reasonable
and then we
create behavioral clones of
um humans
by having an lstm just
just learn to act like humans act uh
including the variance of
how people act and so this is a
this is what the data set looks like
under one condition so this is the
episode people start on the first trial
they either give half or they give
everything and by the end of the episode
no one contributes anything this is in
the social dilemma uh situation where
there's no referee
so everybody starts to defect
and
the lstm if you make four copies of it
have this lstm play the other copies you
unroll a game you unroll hundreds of
games thousands of games that's like the
data set you would then get like the
population
uh on a whole produces a similar pattern
so that's this step here we create a
model
uh with imitation learning
but that's not the critical thing we
don't want to like model what's there
what we want is an agent that learns a
new policy which means it has to explore
uh and try new things that aren't
actually in the data set
that
the lstm was trained with
it wants it needs to come up with new
things
uh as it trains against a simulation
populated with these behavioral clones
and as it tries these new things these
variable clones need to act like real
humans would act under that same
situation so the generalization needs to
basically uh anticipate how humans would
act under this new mechanism policy and
if that works
then this last step will work which is
that we take this agent out of the
simulation put it back on the internet
have it play against the baseline
and
if
and then we want new people to say yes i
prefer this policy over the baseline uh
then it the generalization has worked so
it's sort of like sim to real but with
human
um
[Music]
this is the training pipeline so as i
said you unroll two games with you
create four of your lstms uh unroll a
game under this is the strongest
baseline we made i'll explain that in a
minute but this is the strongest
baseline and we made our lives quite
difficult because it's really strong uh
and you enroll a game under our agent
and then you simulate a vote and how
many votes you get that's the reward
that's flowing up here and is adjusting
the network weights of the agent that's
the training pipeline and the result is
we do win so this is
what
that analysis looks like we only care
about the votes that's what the reward
was that we wanted to maximize
this is now our mechanism against what
we call the libertarian baseline i'll
explain that in a minute uh
we split it up for the tail players so
the players that are less money and the
head players and you see our agents very
popular with the tail players
not so popular with the head players but
that's fine because they're three of
them and we want to win the overall vote
and we do
but we don't just do this in one
setting but we do it in five different
endowment conditions and against three
different baselines
and we win in 13 and we draw on two
so
overall this works
now they're quite that's already
surprising but of course the question is
like what has it learned like that's now
you know how can you be good at this
game what is it that people actually
want from you
that they will vote for you so uh so
let's try to visualize these policies um
all of them with baselines and the agent
are just like feed forward and they have
no memory so they just take the inputs
of the current time step and just output
these actions so we can uh plot the
policy by this this is one time step and
how much the head player contributed so
this is they gave zero coins this they
give 10 coins and we collapse the tail
players to one player so this is all the
tail players contributed everything this
is none of the tail players contribute
anything this corner means everybody
contributed everything
and then the color is how much did the
players get from that policy so
libertarian just
simply gives you back proportional to
how much you
contributed the more you give the more
you get back
and that's why it has these nice
straight lines and it is yellow here
which is if the head player is the only
one contributing they are the only one
getting anything back it is dark blue if
the tail players are the only ones
making contribution they get all of it
and
if everybody contributes everything it's
somewhat in the middle
as you can imagine this actually does
completely solve the social dilemma like
if everybody's just incentivized to give
everything all the time
you do maximize the surplus but it also
preserves the initial inequality like it
never redistributes any money um liberal
egalitarian is what we came up with to
solve this problem it's the same thing
it gives back people proportionally to
what they gave but it's normalized by
how much they had so if you give two out
of two and someone else gets 10 out of
10 the mechanism says that's great you
gave 100 so i consider that to be equal
and that's why the lines are nice and
straight but the whole color scheme is
shifted to blue that means for the same
coordinate the tail players get more
just because their contributions are
increased
what this does is it still incentivizes
contributions but it also redistributes
wealth but it's not perfect because it
can be that the head player is actually
incentivized to defect now if too much
money is being redistributed
um
so now that you know these two baselines
which are already i mean this is the
baseline you would come up with just
from the standard economics literature
right because that just sets the
incentives perfectly this is already
anticipating that there is a strong
notion of fairness that people might
care about how can you do even better
this is what the agent comes up with
no more of these nice straight lines
um so first of all the color scheme is
exactly like liberal egalitarian so like
it's it has very it gives a similar
amount to people
it obviously
it gives
extreme yellow and blue
to the play if those are the only
players who are contributing so if the
head player gives everything they're the
only ones getting anything uh but the
other thing that's interesting so it
does wealth redistribution the other
thing that it does is it really expands
these corners where defectors are
punished so here if you give a little
bit more you get a little bit more back
so it's sort of a linear relationship
this is a rectified linear relationship
where it basically says you get nothing
until you give half
and then
above this threshold we will consider
your contribution so it is very harsh
but also interpretable and that's what
the agent came up with
because people wanted that
um so this is how we can analyze how
games uh shake out overall every dot
here is a game and on the y-axis you
have the wealth that was being created
so this is high if everybody contributes
everything and then the outcome
inequalities on the x-axis how much
people actually took home and as you can
imagine strict egalitarian is the one
that creates a social dilemma and
everybody gets the same outcome there's
a lot of mass on the left which means
the outcome's relatively equal but
there's not a lot of mass on the top so
not a lot of wealth was created
libertarian that gives back
proportionally creates a lot of mass at
the top because everybody's incentivized
to contribute a lot but there's also a
lot of mass on the right of games that
turned out very unequal
our agent and liberal egalitarian are
pretty good at pushing all the all the
dots in the top left corner of the games
that turned out uh
equal and
prosperous but what's interesting about
that is the agent obviously didn't know
that that's what the game is about like
obviously you know that the game is
about
uh
first of all the the trade-off between
equality and uh surplus and also the
conflict between a wealthy minority and
a democratically uh powerful majority
the agent doesn't know that doesn't know
any of these things it doesn't know
these dimensions the agent just knows
makes the votes go up
uh so i think that's pretty cool
that it did that maybe you don't think
it's cool maybe you think the agent is
bad because the baselines are bad there
are two
harder baselines
conceptually harder that should be doing
pretty well one is humans
humans can take the role of the
mechanism play online they get this
interface they see what happened on the
trial they decide who mud who gets back
how much
and the humans
they have a lot more going on they have
they have memory and they don't have to
be impartial or deterministic like our
agent does our agent has no concept of
treating player two differently than
player three like if if they give the
same inputs they have to receive the
same outputs but humans are not as
popular as our agent
[Music]
when you play an episode against the
agent and episode against humans uh the
players on the internet really like our
agent better the other thing you might
say is do you need this whole thing with
the behavioral cloning and like that
that's a
lot of work couldn't you just create a
simulation where
uh
the
virtual players are just maximizing
their reward in a pretty straightforward
way and wouldn't that give you most of
what's going on in this game and we did
that so we just created bots that are
optimal learners that sort of figure out
if they're in a social dilemma or not
and if they are in a social level they
stop contributing and if you optimize a
mechanism on those bots you get this
policy here which looks reasonable you
know it's yellow it should be yellow
it's blue where it should be blue but it
just hasn't honed in on the right
idiosyncrasies so although this task is
quite simple
people still behave in a way
that is like pretty specific they have a
lot of quirks and what then how they
behave and what they want
um
okay so
i was talking about that
this was about removing assumptions and
removing like knowledge we didn't want
to assume
how people behave or what they should
want but we still have slipped some
assumptions in there
by creating an initial data set where
people were playing against a
bunch of baselines and also the agent
had access to a baseline during
training so we now want to remove both
of these things and we want to say let's
start from scratch that we have no data
and we have no idea how to solve this
task because beforehand we said
uh we don't know what the right answer
is there's there's no ground truth here
but we have some ideas of what people
might want and that we can like put
online and gather some data on so here
we say we don't know anything we start
from random and we only optimize from
self-play so we do not
optimize against the baseline
um so here's what that looks like
uh you create a network with random
weights fixed put it online have it play
against itself and then ask people did
you like referee a or b they don't
realize it's the same policy because the
games happen differently
then we have it we model that data set
we distill that into lstms populate the
simulation have the agent now play
against itself in self-play get a little
bit better
that agent we deploy again online
to play against itself and we append
that data to the data set that we have
make it bigger
model that
create a rich create another simulation
and just keep going around this loop and
we check if it converges or we check if
there are any cycles but having a meta
game where all the mechanisms that we
train so far play against each other
under the
biggest
human model that we have until that
point and you can see it just gets
better and better but like you know it
converges and then once we feel it
converges we play against the liberal
egalitarian baseline again this is the
first time this mechanism sees a
baseline and we win again
and i think that was very surprising
that that worked uh it's even cooler
when you see how the policy
evolved because this is the policy that
we started with so this is like
the plot that i already explained but
like for all the different endowment
conditions
and it is actually yellow where it
should be blue and blue where it should
be yellow so the first
random initialization did completely the
opposite of what you should be doing it
gave people more if they contributed
less that's a terrible
thing to try in this task but still the
data that we gathered was good enough
although it was just 300 people it was a
small data set it was good enough in one
step of optimization that this agent
learns that up us up and down is down
and you should give people more if they
give you give them more back if they
contribute more and over the seven steps
it just like
refines this policy until it looks
pretty similar to what we had uh where
we uh in the previous method where we
like built one big
uh model out of one big data set here we
have seven small data sets that actually
add up to be much smaller than the
original one but we come up with a very
very similar solution
um so the benefits of this are we do not
inject any domain knowledge
and
we use a lot less data
the reason for that is because it is
sort of philosophically a bit more
sophisticated so you're not saying we
built one big model that tries to
capture everything that humans could
ever do we're just saying we expect that
people's policy will change as we put
them in a different situation so we just
gather a little bit of human data then
we change what we do
and then we know people will act a
little bit differently so we gather a
little bit more data from this policy
and we like uh iterate a couple of times
um
so in conclusion we demonstrate two
pipelines
to train agents to help humans cooperate
based on human preferences to create an
ai that is shaped by the population that
it interacts with this agent learns to
under award low contributions and to
over-reward
players with low endowments to win
elections and i think by analyzing the
policy we also learned something new
about what humans want like this was
sort of a surprising solution i think
um
but there are important limitations one
is uh voting by majority can
disenfranchise minorities which is why a
lot of democracies have constitutions
uh and you can do something similar as
the designer of the agent for example we
made the choice that the agent doesn't
have memory and we made the choice that
it's a graph net that cannot distinguish
the individual players
these are like design choices you can
still make uh
mechanisms should ideally be transparent
and interpretable of course in the real
world if they involve humans they never
are
but
uh
here again we've shown
in this setting you could analyze the
policy if you want like a complicated
video game and you need a recurring
neural network to handle it then it will
get a lot harder the and the last one is
of course how much bias do you want to
should you introduce you could create an
existing data set in which case you
inject a lot of your own knowledge or a
lot of your assumptions of what possible
solutions are or you could use an
existing data set that already the world
has produced in which case again you are
tied to the world that exists rather
than the world it could be
if however you want to
move away from that and say let's reduce
let's have less domain knowledge and
just start with the data with no data
then you have to experiment online and
that of course might not be safe or
practical to just like gather data under
policies that aren't necessarily good
um
so
just to uh
sum this up
and i think this connects a lot with the
previous talk is the fact that this
works
hints at
that it seems like human behavior and
human preferences about this seem to lie
on a smooth manifold that these sort of
methods can handle
and the question i'm really excited
about is
if you choose a more complicated setting
will these methods still work or do you
need more sophisticated
models of humans or do you need more
sophisticated methods of
training your agent
thank you that is all i have these are
the papers that i
mentioned awesome thank you
questions
hi yeah this was very interesting very
nice work um i was wondering were the
participants
given any information about who is the
making the decision for them or do you
think it'd be different if people would
know or could choose between an ai
uh
or a human uh that will separate will
make the distribution if you're the
player um
you will not know anything about how the
policy is generated so it's all you have
to experience it and we're not telling
anyone this is the baseline this is
and do you think that there will be
difference if people can choose between
human or ai as it is
uh
notions that they bring into it i i
couldn't
i actually don't know which way it would
go
um i think in the real world you if you
have to be concerned about that you
would really matter
the potential for sort of more
objectivity if they find that nice
[Music]
so um
quick question just to start it out
in one of the initial slides you said
that um
like there's some private information
that isn't shared
um
are players made aware of the wealth
inequality among the other three players
i think everything is transparent in the
game okay observations include uh what
everybody's talents were and how much
they gave so that's completely
transparent to everyone okay so like
someone who has two coins knows that
there's another person who has ten
okay um
did you analyze
and if so see any patterns in like
voting based on
if the human had 10 coins versus if they
had two
[Music]
is that coins is actually very popular
with netflix so most of the advantage
that the agent has is by um
appealing to the majority
uh yeah that's that's definitely
yeah that's the biggest determiner yeah
okay thanks
okay
uh really amazing stuff uh as probably
one of the minority i'm a behavioral
scientist in the room um so i might ask
questions stupid so apologize in advance
uh i i guess at the more higher level uh
really appreciate that you start with
very few assumptions about human
preferences and try to recover that
through uh through
learning interactions but i'm just
curious uh
would existing data in behavioral
science about
trends in people's behavior behavior
behavior and preferences obviously
there's going to be a large amount of
individual differences do you think
that's going to be a helpful inductive
bias to build into the model instead of
assuming from nothing maybe not i mean
as you mentioned that people prevent
tend to be following a smooth manifold
so i'm just curious about your thought
on
that many different paths
and then to just build a sort of human
model that would like because we just
did one thing for one task but i think
actually using all the existing data and
just building a huge model that works a
lot
because you might also see benefits of
generalization there it's just
[Music]
trained on a really big set of
different tasks you might
be way better generalizing to new
situations and
and then we also actually generalize
across endowment conditions so like not
all the adult conditions that we test on
are actually
but that's sort of an
easy way of generalizing i think from
task to past
amazing and it could use data right i
think there are tons of data from
behavioral science across different
kinds of either from economists or
psychologists
that a meta-analysis might serve as a
reasonable starting point for uh for
maybe building a more generalized yeah
thanks
um so you mentioned one of the
limitations is that um
that this system favors the majority and
this could disenfranchise the minority
i'm curious if you have like any ideas
about how to deal with this um
like possibly like the voting system you
use is based on popularity do you think
maybe like choosing the wing winning
mechanism as the mechanism that is uh
like disagreed with the least as an
alternative that could solve this
so the reason why i don't think it's a
huge issue for this is because that's
just how economic inequality works that
uh the
the more empowered people are the
minority so it's sort of about this
conflict
but i don't think it's an issue in this
particular case in
general i think a lot could be done to
make
what we just have as the vote which is
just a very quick binary choice between
two experiences you had to make that
more meaningful like you could either
ask people to just think about it longer
to do it on a longer time scale to ask
them after that sometimes think about it
you could also
give them a scenario
where you
tell them in the next episode you don't
know how many coins you're going to have
so the
answer you need to give us needs to
generalize to you maybe being in a
different situation and there are all
sorts of framings that you could do
to get
a better um measure of the thing you
want to maximize because you could
if
people aren't actually
if this expression of the vote is not
actually capturing what we want to
capture then like it's optimizing for
the wrong thing i think this is like
definitely
a big
uh area of improvement is to make this
work like more meaningful and capturing
better what people want especially long
term
super interesting yeah i guess a voting
schemes on voting schemes
okay so let's thank rafael again for
that awesome talk